if you're not familiar with this channel
my name is beer pop I do 100% let's
place with zero deaths I'm a pro gamer
everyone knows me by that the last Crash
Bandicoot video I did everyone was like
oh you have to play the bridge level the
bridge level is the hardest with the
branch level Felix I swear the bridge
level is just like Dark Souls the rest
is now maybe more blood-borne but their
bridge level that's Dark Souls oh well
look at that I have the bridge level
right here and I'm going to play it for
you ye sons of [ __ ] ok easy I pledge
it never played this so it says danger
that's just like Dark Souls oh wow this
is extremely difficult I must be very
lucky so far to have made it this far in
the competition
now some scrubs struggle with those kind
of jumps I don't because I'm not
zero deaths everyone zero deaths here we
try let's go let's do that
how's it going bro I'm just starting up
this new level I have not died yet which
is [ __ ] hell why did I i'll they just
insta break what a [ __ ] load of [ __ ]
of all ends to break your ass that's why
ok I get it
is this [ __ ] Boris back the bore act
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was act well so he can run
over whatever the [ __ ] okay okay that
makes sense okay so he can run over
holds this [ __ ] I didn't know I had to
be a [ __ ] pig to play this game also
what the [ __ ] he can't die also sorry I
didn't realize Crash Bandicoot was a
Bandicoot sorry I don't know what the
[ __ ] a Bandicoot is what the [ __ ] well
what the [ __ ] easy
when does this level get hard everyone
what a fun for real it for realsies is
this supposed to be hard like I can't
tell are you guys strolling me is this
one of your trolls oh you got you got me
this this isn't actually hard Wow oh
look at checkpoint just like Dark Souls
they have a ton of them [ __ ] off you
[ __ ] pig this pig is such a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all Pig got trapped boy pig gut trap boy
is this supposed to be hard
[ __ ] zero - how many [ __ ] yo you Pig son
of a [ __ ] zero dicks everybody welcome
everyone number one welcome we're
starting off this let's play out [ __ ]
you man there must have been some hay
sort of collection there system what
does game over mean I I never heard
those words before it must mean the
system is bugged
okay well let's here we go at least I
know [ __ ] you at least I know I [ __ ]
can't jump on those okay easy never died
on this level this is supposed to be the
hardest level ever okay which means it's
gonna be [ __ ] easy can I at least see
where I'm going thank you now you know
what I don't even need to see where I'm
going I could play this blind I'm
legally blind actually I never told you
bros but I'm actually blind I've been
playing all my games blind that's right
that's how skilled I am I listen to the
sound and I smell I smell their interior
and that's how I'm so good the doctors
told me hey you want some eyes I'm like
do I want easy-mode in life what the
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] [ __ ] I think Jeb
like didn't speak doc there you go so
easy so [ __ ] easy this game is easier
than tapping Your Mama's ass boy boy boy
boy easy
aza okay alright zero deaths z-ro mother
flippin [ __ ] [ __ ] ass licking
mother [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that
it's still easy though legit just watch
just watch just watch
boom bada bing bazinga as I always say
my catchphrase everyone knows it it's
just supposed to let is this legit like
Oh shucks a Bandicoot oh it's the slider
that makes it hard right [ __ ] what
[ __ ] what when is this game when does
this game whoa [ __ ] homeless
[ __ ] me hey boy you want somebody's ass
ah that's too bad byeeeee oh oh well
that's a little difficult zero deaths
[ __ ] you Zehra that atha a lot of people
don't know this but I was actually born
in this game that's why I'm so good at
it because I know the ins and outs too
bad I never [ __ ] die if I if I do die
then I'm sure that would be difficult
but as a great man 1 well that's clearly
too far to jump
welcome everyone just starting up this
continuing part 2 of this let's play
we're playing the bridge level met about
a fetus yeah block cubed Lube that live
that does anyone know what the [ __ ] he
says I heard the back yeah we're gonna
make do you know what makes me so good
at games I'll tell you my secret
respecting women that's right and
deadliness alright alright a lot of
people don't know like I respected women
before it was trendy to do so all these
people hopping on the bandwagon now
saying they respect women and [ __ ] but
I've been respecting women for a very
very long time at least a couple months
okay
I'm every day I wake up I put on my
clothes I take a shower I [ __ ] your Pig
a lot of people don't realize I respect
women so much that I am becoming one and
that's not a trans joke that's nope
okay that is that of one maybe alright
respect the women boom done
respect respecting still respecting
that's right I'm still respecting that's
why I'm not having died yet that's right
look at that so much respect such pure
loving respect at all that respect I'm
giving right now bros this is this is
giving making me teary-eyed look at that
look at that all that respect what l
that respect come from how does he have
so much in him you know that's what I
can you give me a one checkpoint here
for [ __ ] sake that's so much jumping
are you kidding me why do they have to
put the [ __ ] bore there Zarek [ __ ]
[ __ ] zero deaths everyone zero I can't
even make it to the impossible [ __ ]
gentleman
like a [ __ ] far after go every time
my name job la mouche caca now I'm
getting pissed all right I don't know
how to beat this [ __ ] thing all right
mr. turtle [ __ ] off okay okay all right
I get it you just got a charge off that
respect charging charging charging oh
wow zero I gotta do all this [ __ ] again
Jesus I mean for the first time because
I never died ah didn't get his feet doc
come here by the blip [ __ ] you [ __ ]
boo blood guy you're supposed to have my
[ __ ] back all right come in with
[ __ ] say that [ __ ] boy you say that
disrespect that's your [ __ ] respect
right [ __ ] there you see that [ __ ]
respect them
every [ __ ] day son oh [ __ ] No
no she's had an impossible jump in the
game another time yeah good idea man I
like your statement here over an
activation we're [ __ ] hard all the
time ah this [ __ ] jump I swear to
[ __ ] god I don't [ __ ] get it okay
oh oh how did I do it how did I do it
how did I do I did it with my wrist my
wrist pay respect respect respect
respect respect respect respect respect
[Music]
I'm the well I didn't care about the
boxes because boxes are for women well
thank you very much this perfect oh look
at that it looks like I got it perfect
after all Wow easy game na ha ha
just like Dark Souls that's what they
share they're both for women thank you
so much and leave a like if you are
feeling like you could